[Music]  this is pierre a hooded vulture native  to sub-saharan africa hooded vultures  are critically endangered they are the  smallest of african vultures only  slightly larger than a crow  they are scavengers and because of their  small size they end up waiting by  carcasses and eating the scraps left  behind by bigger birds adults have white  feathers behind the neck which forms a  hood over its head they live in forest  clearings where it rains coastal marshes  and lagoons hooded vultures are unafraid  of humans and can be found in villages  and towns often referred to as garbage  collectors by locals due to a  combination of hunting poisoning and  habitat degradation their population of  the last three generations has declined  or the 80 percent this is the hooded  vulture  you  [Music]